[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to the
endgame class
as always my name is caleb denby and
today i'm going to be taking you through
some very exciting rook and games that's
right
once again i am talking about rook
endgames
in the previous couple lectures i did a
lot
of sort of theoretical positions right
positions that i could talk about for a
long long time
that we still to be honest have not
reached the the bottom of there's always
more to explore in those positions you
can talk about them for hours and hours
and hours
but tonight i wanted to take those
theoretical positions that we
have been learning and see what they
they look like in actual games putting
them
to the test as you might say so we're
gonna look at a few
really famous games that uh
ended up in some very complex rook end
games
and we're going to see if we can figure
out where each side is making mistakes
and and why they they are in fact
mistakes and how they can improve
so let's just jump into it i'm going to
flip over here
and our first game is going to be
between
uh wolfgang uh unzicker
and eric rubin lunden and ignore that
text that showed
it's no longer the skilling open that
was last class
uh now it's all rook and games so let's
get to it nobody cares about this nobody
this is not a rook end game what are we
talking about there's a queen on the
board
okay all right rook's on the board i'm
not even gonna be talking about this
though
because we see now yes that's right
we are arriving at the glorious
glorious rook endgame so
here we are this may be a position
reasonably familiar to you guys
if you were watching last week you'll
know
so much about this position with the
pieces
situated a little bit differently right
we were looking at this
position with the pawn on a6 the rook on
a7 and the king on f3
and we said that position is in fact
a draw but not very easily
at all we saw a myriad of ways both
sides can go
wrong ways to throw away the win ways
for black to throw away the draw
and it's it's a very tight line that
both both sides have to
have to walk like it's not easy at all
to play these end games
so here what we have is uh
a position where white actually has the
rook on the side of the pawn
black's king is in pretty good position
on f6
and black's rook is behind the pawn we
know that if white zurich were behind
the pawn
that'd be a very different story white
is almost always winning
in those cases unless if you remember
black can make a past pawn on
the king side for counter play so what's
going on here
i'd like to get the chat room's thoughts
on this what i'm calling our sort of
initial position i skipped through some
stuff a little bit earlier
a few moves in the shuriken game this is
the first position i really want to talk
about
so what's going on should white be
winning should black be drawing easily
what are sort of the ideas for both
sides here how many lines tonight
so last lecture i like to brag
i spent the entire hour talking about
one position
this time i do have a variety of games
that i have prepped i i have no idea to
be honest how many of them we're going
to get to
depends on how in depth we we actually
get here
be easy says black is actually winning
here superior king position
but um maybe not maybe maybe not
everybody thinks it should be a draw
black should give up the f pawn for the
a and try to hold
king plus rook plus two versus king plus
rook plus three so
uh i personally am on the side of the
people
that think it's a draw however what pip
and chuck just said is very
optimistic thinking very very optimistic
that you think white is going to let you
have this pawn
for this pawn spawn's worth way more no
way is that going to happen
so of course we were analyzing um
a lot of variations with the pawn on a6
the rook on a7 with the king and f3
where white was able to jettison um
the kingside pawns in favor of advancing
the pawn to a7
getting the rook on c7 and then we had
all these clever ideas of
checking the king and putting the rook
behind the pawn to interfere with the
other rook right we had all these clever
ideas
however there is sort of an alternate
plan in this
exact position that white has white
doesn't necessarily have to put the rook
in front of the pawn
white can put the rook in front of the
pawn and go for similar positions by
pushing this pawn forward
but white doesn't necessarily have to
this isn't you know forced by any
stretch of the imagination
so what is the secondary plan for white
what what else could white try
in this position there's another very
very important plan
that you have to be aware of
another important plan
so for those of you who haven't watched
any of the previous lectures
usually the character of these end games
is that white
tries to force black to sacrifice the
rook for the pawn
and black tries to advance the king's
side pawns far enough and win white's
king side pawns
in the process so that black can draw
with the pawns against the rook
force white to sacrifice the rook for
the pawns
and then draw the game so how does that
make any sense
well it turns out to force the rook to
sacrifice itself white needs the king on
this side of the board
and by leaving the king's side that is
when these pawns
sort of become vulnerable so that is the
winning plan
and the drawing plan in these positions
generally
so chess king says f3 g4 and that is not
going to be the right idea here
those types of pawn trades putting
tension on the king's side
is really only going to be beneficial to
black it's a lot better
to have one passed pawn against two then
zero passed pawns against one and we've
seen that
in previous lectures where black's
drawing idea
is to sort of sacrifice one of these
uh king side pawns as a past pawn for
white's outside pass pawn
and then draw the ensuing rook and game
with one v zero
right one v zero tends to be a draw
especially with the black king in front
of the pawn
so that's not it so jacob molina has the
right idea
rook f4 and walk the king over
and what does black do what does black
do against this plan
right it's not so easy to tell if you
pass and just keep an eye on this pawn
you know it's it's not as if white isn't
making progress here right
uh like like look out look out all of a
sudden wait a second
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa white's rookie
got got behind the pawn
like white circus behind the pawn now
it's easily winning easily winning
we just push push push and it's over
push push push and it's over
it doesn't matter that black is
blockading because now
our king is going to be able to invade
right part of the problem here for black
is
you can never pass for example if you
move the rook i push up
you just can never pass so white's gonna
break through example you go here
i pass and eventually i will get into
the position
and win all your pawns so what
should black do against this plan from
white
rook f4 check and yeah vinnie has the
right idea
as always black's play has to come on
the king's side you have to find counter
play on the king's side
and the only way to stay in the game for
black is to go
uh first i think with king g7 you don't
really want to get your king
locked out of the king's side in this
case and while white is running the king
over
we'll see black find counter play on the
king's side by going f6
and g5 and this is enough for a draw
here
for black for example takes takes
rook over to b4 for example and i think
even h4
is enough to draw here for example if
you take this guy
i take this guy and good luck winning
this end game my rook is behind your
pawn
or and also you know
okay just yeah this end game's just a
draw trust me this end game is a draw
for example king c1
isn't going to be good enough um
a5 for example we can just
blockado and bring the king over
so i wanted to highlight this idea
though
i wanted to highlight this idea rook f4
check it can sometimes be
a very very very powerful idea
to defend the pawn from the side
provided
that you can defend both the pawn and
your own backwards
your own king side pawns at the same
time that's why defending the pawn from
the side can be valuable
you get sort of the best of both worlds
you're able to run the king to the queen
side
and keep all of your king's side pawns
and it's important to realize that with
black
you need to do something against this
plan you need to have a response against
this plan
in this case f6 g5 is going to be good
enough and just to show one more line
there
let's say f6 g5
now also importantly if white doesn't
take this which might be tempting
now black can in fact start going after
the pawns on
f2 for example and now if a5
come back here and this pawn is dead
so perhaps this is better sorry say
brooke
well we'll say rook c4 happy middle
right
and here black is going to push this
pawn and once again
it will be a successful decoy and black
will be able to take white's past pawn
okay so all of that is to say rook f4
interesting idea but it doesn't work
here right everybody on board with this
so pip and chuck says if instead of king
g7 king e5
and your point is king you want f5 but i
was never interested
i was never never never interested in
taking your pawn on f7 the power of the
rook on f4 isn't that i'm threatening to
win black's king side's pawns
so that i'm preventing you from winning
mine right so you can play f5
and you can run your king over here i
don't care you can do whatever you want
all i care about is uh getting your rook
out from behind
my own past pawn and then here
maybe somehow actually it's it's gonna
still be difficult for me
interesting uh maybe now i can actually
consider
this idea which i previously said was
ridiculous of going f3 and g4
what's the point the point is now your
king's no longer over here
and this may in fact cause you some some
problems
maybe not though i think this should be
a draw so maybe your idea is actually uh
actually a good one here maybe this is
actually a good one although i do
suspect
that i do have some stronger stronger
ideas here
sometimes i can come after this pawn but
i'm not going to make any claims
to my eyes it looks like this might be
good enough but
believe me it's absolutely impossible to
just on the fly give you an evaluation
of these positions there's a lot of
specifics to take into account
but it looks like that idea is good
enough but
i will say in general go for counterplay
on the king's side
don't go for some fortress type looking
thing
because a lot of times white will have a
plan for improvement that you have to
look out for
so i like this plan because it sort of
keeps in line with our thinking our
general principle
black draws by achieving counter play on
the king side
all of that is to say though rook f4
check not good enough to win the game
which is why probably
wolfgang goes for rook b6 check black
goes with king f5
and this is the right idea in my opinion
why is this the right idea uh well
because in these end games like i keep
saying
black achieves the draw by finding
counter play
on the king's side and that means having
an active king king f5
is absolutely the right the right way to
start here
you could play king g7 but then your
king is actually going to be cut off on
the sixth rank
and this will introduce some other
problems uh to black as we'll actually
see
and i think game number two or or three
maybe game number three
but to start with king f5 is the right
idea now rook a6 was white's point
transferring the rook in front of the
pawn
now we see king e5 a5 king e4
rook a7 and here black plays the move f6
so i would like to get the chat room's
opinion
on the move pawn to f6
chat room what is your opinion of this
move
i had a maxim the other day about rook
in front of pawn
uh i don't think i did the maximus
rooks belong behind past pawns in this
case though
obviously white cannot achieve that so
the question was the rook in front of
the pawn or the rook to the side of the
pawn
and we saw with rook f4 check why the
rook on the side of the pawn
is not good enough for a win so what's
left well what's left is putting the
work in front of the pawn so you can
advance it
why not rook a8 immediately uh well
we've seen in many cases
that having the rook on a7 can be better
thanks to some of those lines that we
saw
with rook c7 uh
and sometimes okay sometimes it's better
to have the rook on a7 why is that well
if the rook ever leaves behind the a
pawn then we are
occasionally threatening to capture the
pawn on f7
obviously in this case we were not
threatening to capture the pawn on f7
for example king e5 we're not going to
take this guy because this end game is a
very easy
very simple draw for black two versus
three always going to be a draw
but black plays this move f6 so
then he just says no which is fair uh
you know i understand that sentiment
entirely
why can't black play king of three well
that's probably what black was thinking
you can't go king of three here because
then this move is check
right not so easy not so easy after all
energy says not a good move because
black has to get king's side counter
play as fast as
possible so
i'm asking the chat pip and chuck what
do you think about this move
of pawn to f6 so it turns out
this move is not the greatest
but it's sort of a very very deep reason
why and it goes back to the lecture i
taught
on having the pawn on the seventh rank
we'll see that all of these ideas end up
being connected
in these end games so here with the rook
in front of the pawn
f6 turns out to be a move that very much
gives white some very serious winning
chances now
i'm not going to pretend that i know the
evaluation
of all of these positions like after
every each
half move i have it all saved
and and i i can reference it but um
i don't have that just just memorize i
think after f6
that black may actually just be losing
with good play but we'll
we'll see we'll see what happens in the
game and see why that might be
so f6 not a good move but i won't tell
you why just yet you have to to wait and
see
so what should black have done instead
well i think in my opinion
uh there is a very easy way to
deaden the game immediately here with
with black
so nicodem actually has the right idea
in the chat so i'm not even gonna
gonna ask you guys f5 this is the move
that would have been essentially ending
the game
uh for black here why is this the move
that
is like you know removing all all
winning chances for white
well the idea is simple we go f4
and we get this king side counter play
that i was
talking about it's it's really just that
easy this is
the only thing going on here black is
able to force weaknesses on the king
side
make a past pawn and then draw on the
benefits of that past pawn
and notably this idea of bringing the
pawn to the seventh rank is in fact
going to be a little bit too slow here
thanks to king f3 uh
when i think anything here is is good
enough to win
but perhaps simplest is this move
when of course you're never winning this
position don't
really have time for this because now
you lose to checkmate
and black is doing fine so f5 f4
would have been a great drawing idea now
i think honestly even the move king e5
should be enough to draw
why is king e5 enough to draw well by
not changing the position
black is in this theoretical position
that we already know about
that that is just going to be
theoretically drawn for example
a6 even king back to f6 can be played
and we've seen this one before and in
fact we've even seen
this one before and even this if black
gets the king out to f or white gets the
king
out to f3 is a draw this is exactly the
position we spent an hour talking about
uh in the last lecture king e4 is the
best troy
g5 ends the game um of course it's not
not quite that simple
so f6 changes the position and
my advice to you is only do this if you
are
absolutely certain that you have a
drawing idea and that your drawing idea
is
is good enough to uh to hold so in the
game
white goes king to g2
goes king to g2
so how should black continue now how
should black continue now
and jerk says if the black king gets cut
off from his pawns and loses the f-pawn
white has serious winning chances so
again it's tough to make
serious generalizations on all of those
end games
but in general black is able to draw
even with the king cut off along the e
file even with the king
on d5 or d4 black is is close enough
with the king in general
to uh to get a draw there so with the
king on the e file it's generally not
even close
it's just always going to be a draw
g5 is wrong i know that so g5 is is the
right way to think
g5 is absolutely the right way to think
but
white to move and come up with an
absolute stunner here g5
you're thinking along the right track
you need king side counter play
you need it in your life
but white to play here
so here's what white shouldn't do white
shouldn't take here
and allow black to to play something
like h4
um although maybe this is coming
uh quickly enough here maybe this is
coming quickly enough
uh let's say though black plays a little
bit stronger and now a7 doesn't win due
to king g7 i i should say
the reason why h4 doesn't work here is
because uh
let's say something like this
um this even king of five the point is
now white is always able to leave from
in front of the pawn and win with the
pawn on the seventh ring
so that's why h4 is wrong but if black
brings the king back to g6
that idea no longer wins and once again
black is going to make a decoy
with the past h pawn and get the draw
so that's what white shouldn't do what
should white do and yeah the chatroom
has it now
the stunning move is g4 and this
is uh just just ending the game now just
ending the game
the best try is h takes g4 but now h5
king f5 for example
uh now h6 h7 and this rook on a7 comes
in handy
the game the game is just over the game
is just
over um this doesn't help it's the exact
same
so g5 doesn't quite work and it turns
out now after king g2
f6 f5 is also too slow which is why i
think black is just losing
after the move f6 so f6 now
we go uh either rook a8 or i think a6
either one and what's the point
well the point is now f3 check we go
king
h3 uh
and hear what's going on yeah i think
just a seven
and you're not in time with this
counterplay that was working
by a tempo previously so
that leaves one idea for black that
leaves one idea for black this quick
king side counter play stuff just wasn't
working out so you go king f5
now does anyone in chat know the winning
plan for white here
do you remember from the lecture i think
two weeks ago
two weeks ago what's the winning plan
for white
winning plan
it's not it's not a very intuitive one
if you guys don't remember
i sincerely doubt you'll be able to come
up with it on
the fly here
get the king to c4 and rook c7 to c5
plus
plus minus a4 okay so i get what pip and
chuck is saying
he's saying this idea that we looked at
uh in
last week's lecture not two weeks ago
where we go a6 which we can start with
this absolutely
and let's say you get everything let's
say
you get everything you ever wanted okay
i'm not going to fight back
i'm not going to fight back okay even if
you get
um this position even if you get this
position
black is drawing here why is black
drawing here
well in this case f6 turns out to be a
very useful move
in this case you make f6 out to be
a useful move rather than rather than a
mistake
why is that well let's look at the
ensuing variations
so king g4 for example
uh and let's say uh
king b3 yeah we'll start with king b3
rook a
one we'll say so sorry i'm going the
wrong
king b3 doesn't make sense here why
doesn't king b3 make sense here because
their rook's not on c7 yet so
white should go for this plan of putting
the king in front of the pawn
and here black is just going to continue
with
i guess rook takes f2 is the most
accurate now for example rook c7
i'm going for this plan
take a7 or k2
and now after king b7
uh black has an improvement so in
previous variations
with the pawn on f7 black was always
having to play king takes h4
and by the way it's possible i didn't do
the most accurate sequence just then
but the point still stands black has an
improvement over king takes h4
black's play actually comes a lot a lot
faster
with the move g5 here and that's why
pawn to f6 is a useful move
against this plan so if the pawns on f6
this plan
shouldn't ever really work black should
always be in time
thanks to this pawn being on f6 to
support this move g5
and sort of quicken the play now black
is making a past pawn
and getting to h1 much faster than
before
so we need a new plan we need a new plan
and which by the way
in the game rook a3 was played here and
now obviously king f3 is
not as easy to uh to achieve
so rookie 8 rook a2 and now king f3 but
now
rook a3 check king e2 king e4
so white to move here wait to move here
and find the winning plan
does anybody see it
does anybody see it
i'll be absolutely astounded if you guys
can tell me the winning plan
without uh having seen it
so f3 f3 is the start i'll give f3 to
you
f3 check you cannot take this pawn
because i will check you
and take your rook so the king backs up
but what's the point what's the point
everybody
what's the point the king backs up
what's the big deal here
what is the big deal
how do you win the game
give mate pip and chuck is close
but before we give mate there's
something else we have to do
[Music]
so once again the idea of g4 is just
never going to be correct here it's
never going to be correct
take take take the only time it was
correct
was when we made an unstoppable past
pawn that's the exception to the rule
here
uh now if you try something like a7
it's true that i can't take this pawn
but it doesn't really matter
i don't know what the simplest is maybe
f5 is simple enough now f5 allows h5
so i'll go king h3 x clamp point now is
if h5
i will take it not king takes h4
allowing rick h8 by the way
and now i'll run this pawn off the board
and we will agree to a draw
so it's not g4 and king d2 isn't it
either why isn't king d2 it well now
black will simply take this guy
this move just is responded to by this
with a similar endgame
and you just aren't really in time for
any of this i think i can even take this
guy
with the point being that i can just
check you
until you let me onto the a file uh
yeah so that's not the plan either can't
run the king
and you can't play g4 so that leaves one
idea you guys are right
that leaves a7
and now comes the magic question guys
how do we win
right we put the we put the pawn on a7
and this does a lot for us
this does a lot this makes sure that
this king on f5
is not able to move can't move this king
anymore that king
is frozen you step out this way i'm
checking you
these moves they're all illegal so this
king is frozen
what does that mean well that means this
rook is doomed to wander the a file
forever
but as we've seen before if you for
example
wander your king all the way up to this
side of the board
you're going to get checked from behind
and you have no shelter
you have just no shelter so
how do you win the game after a seven
how do you win the game king to h3
king to h3 isn't really going to make a
difference either
why not well i'll tell you
play a move right you're not going to
play g4 because i'm going to take it
and e there's actually no real way to
triangulate here right i just don't step
to a3 until you step to h3
and so this too is just a draw
get the king to f7 rook c8 rook c5 check
that would be great that would be great
king f7 rook c8
but then rook takes a7 is actually going
to be
check but chess king is close chess king
is close
close to the right idea there chess king
master zeus asks is that water or
russian water
and unfortunately this is just regular
water here today
king f7 doesn't work guys rook takes a7
comes with check you have no time
to move the rook out from front of the
pawn and jack
jefferson is here with the right idea
the point is not king h3
point is not king f7 the point is you
put the king all the way on h6 perhaps
the furthest square away on the board
that's as far away as you can get
that's a long journey but it's the
journey that white's going to make
and it turns out it's a journey that's
good enough to win the game
why is it good enough to win the game
well let's see how unzicker
continues here king d4 black tries to
stop the king from entering but of
course
black has no passing moves so you you
have to let the king in
rook a one now so if king b6 once again
we get checked forever
king d6 though is on zicker's choice now
rook a3
is an empty threat black can never take
this or else i will queen
king e7 rook a6 king f7
rook a3 king g7 rook a1
and now king h6 rook a6
and what's the point why is our king on
h6
why did we put our king here did he see
that from the beginning maybe
maybe it's possible
it's possible
pip and chuck says rook g8
villi says g4 and chess king says rook
b8 so three competing ideas here
uh once again g4 not gonna be the idea
we take take and take not good enough
not good enough to win the game um
taking this
just isn't gonna do it we go f5 check
can go somewhere and i think we can even
take this
i think we can even take this
now with your king behind my pawn like
this it's sort of almost as far away
as if it was on b7 in fact i think these
two squares are equidistant from this
from this pawn well more specifically
they're equidistant from the e4 square
believe it or not
one two three and one two three it may
not look like it but chest geometry is
different than normal geometry is
no euclidean geometry here okay
this square in this square same distance
from this guy
so that's always going to be a draw not
g4 not g4
and rick g8 also not going to be the
idea
once again black is able to draw the
game
i believe this time not so easily
but this position should also be a draw
maybe not
maybe rick g8 is technically good enough
to win
yeah apparently g4 here is is
technically winning but
white need not trouble himself with
looking at this because rick b
is is simply much better and the point
now is you don't take g6
with the rook but you do take it with
the king
and now h5 falls and white is just going
to be
two pawns up uh rook 8 played in the
game is a good try
but now king takes g5 rook g8
if you check me then i would run behind
my pawns g4
check here and you can almost take my h
pawn
but when you do i am sadly sadly for you
at least
going to be taking uh taking your f
and two pawns up is always going to be
winning for white
so that's the crazy idea that's the
crazy crazy idea
and that's what i mean when i say all
these rook end games are connected to
each other
in this game unzikr wins because he
knows this idea of having the pawn on
the seventh rank
is winning against this setup by black
and this is just one example of how that
setup can actually
sort of come to be right it's not just
some theoretical setup that's never
going to actually happen
it's a very logical plan for black to
play f6
think about coming with g5 a little bit
later on and then the refutation is
useful to know you put the pawn on a7
you bring the king down and around
around the world
over to h6 and then you you go on and
win the game
and that is our first example of the
night
so in this case i think it was actually
pretty well played by unzicker
obviously black sort of uh
sort of lost his way here with the move
f6
now is black just lost after f6 i think
so but like
again i don't fully remember maybe
there's there's some idea that i'm
missing
but in general f6 i i am very confident
in calling it a mistake
because black should never lose this
game and f6 introduces a whole host
of losing ideas that weren't there
before very nice lesson we're not done
yet
we only spent 40 minutes on one position
tonight so now
i want to go over another game this time
between uh grand master vlad ukopian
not to be confused with a cobian uh
famous saint louis grandmaster
but a copian once again nobody cares
about this part of the chess game
we are interested in the rook and game
uh so here black plays rook d2 coming
after the b pawn
white's really only oh also this guy
white's only winning try
is to come take this a pawn which he
does and we arrive
at this position uh and once again
we see this set up on the king's side
and i mentioned this when i
was talking about the theoretical
position why do we look at the position
with the pawns
in this structure well this is just sort
of the best structure for
both sides there are some nuances to
know in the f4 f5 structure as well
but in general that's a worse idea for
black to go for
and it's a worse idea for white to go
for um as well in many cases so this is
sort of our normal structure and we'll
see the grandmasters sort of understand
this
and are consistently just building the
structure in these rook end games
so with that brief aside i'm going to
fast forward a few moves here
because the players sort of were just
passing back and forth for a while
okay uh so rook a3 check sorry this is
this is the moment that i want to talk
about so here
white has done something really really
interesting number one
white left the pawn on a3 uh
and in doing so allowed his king to
escape out in front of the pawns which
is of course
much more favorable as than having the
king stuck on
f1 for example king in front of the
pawns is always good
number two white has left this rook on
a6 and this
is a great great great winning idea for
white now not saying it wins but i'm
saying it's a great try
to improve your position to the point
where it could become winning
how so well it's stopping the black king
from coming out to f6
and this is of course a very very
relevant idea all of the drawing ideas
that we looked at involved this black
king coming to f6
and playing the move g5 and and that is
of course
the very very important drawing idea to
look out for
now what else has white done well i
guess that's about it got the king in
front of the pawns and left
the rook on a6 now a4
so when i ask you guys in the chat room
here with the black pieces
uh how would you go about trying to draw
this position
how would you try to draw here
so pip and chuck again f3 g4 is almost
never right
because having two pass pawns versus one
is
much worse than having uh one pass pawn
versus zero
so for the last time if you go f5
g4 i'm just passing let's let's say
if i do this it's better pass g4 i'm
going to take it
and play f5 and now
one pass pawn versus two is is a draw
this is just always a draw making a pass
pawn on the king's side is the
antithesis of what white should be doing
black
is trying to make a pass pawn on the
king's side white is trying to use this
pawn to win the game
by forcing black to sacrifice the rook
for it so stop
going for f3 g4 it's not good it's good
for black you are
playing the defensive plan for black in
that case
but how do you try to draw with black
here how do you try to draw
um a4 played in the game by the way so
black to move here
chess king you'll have to to fix your
notation there i'm actually not entirely
certain what you mean
so jacob molina says f6 g5 and
yes rather paradoxically f6 being wrong
in the previous game
is absolutely correct here and it's
important to understand
why why is f6 correct well in
the previous position black was not in
time to play the move g5
why not because white's pieces were too
far advanced right
let's jump back i don't want to do too
much of this but we will jump back for
the moment
um f6 played in
the game and goodness graciously just
did the thing
where it mixed up all the variations
this is the main line okay f6 played in
the game
white goes king g2 and now of course g5
loses to takes takes and a6
when you just simply aren't in time
because white is able to put this pawn
on a7
and win the game now let's contrast this
with
this position let's say white does the
exact same thing
goes a5 we go g5
takes takes um even rook a7 let's say
rook a8 though
h4 takes uh takes
or or king f3 if you prefer i think this
is worse though
so takes takes king f3
uh now h3 a6
and sorry black is winning after after
a6 so you have to go king g3
uh h2 takes and takes
and black is easily drawing in this rook
end game which hopefully you guys all
know
hopefully you guys are familiar with
this one um perhaps rook f5 is the
simplest here
everybody loves vankura who doesn't love
incur right
all right uh okay
so f6 g5 great drawing idea and i'm not
going to pretend there aren't any more
like subtleties and nuances to to know
but f6 g5 in general is the right idea
so uh goryev's
play in the game is is perhaps just
entirely wrong here he goes rook a3
check
which is sort of uh you know reasonable
sort of reasonable you go check and i
think the idea
was probably to go rick a2 and come
capture this pawn on
f2 but then georgiev sort of switches
ideas again
and is like oh wait no no no i'm
supposed to go f6 g5
and unfortunately for black this is
going to be different than the first
time we looked at f6 g5
why is it going to be different well
this was a really crucial tempo
that you just gave up and also by the
way you're no longer attacking my f2
pawn
so two things that are really really
important you know not letting the king
further into the position
and pressuring the kingside pawns in
black abandon both of those ideas
with the move rook a3 check so while it
might be tempting
to play something like rick a3 rook a2
just to try to like force matters force
white to defend this pawn or commit to
giving it up
it's important to understand that that
is just entirely wrong
in this position once again better is
simply passing
even just passing the move back to white
is
better why is it better because now at
least you're not giving up pressure on
this pawn
at least you're not giving up the
pressure on the f2 pawn and white will
continue with something like a5
and the game will will go on from here
but best idea by a far stretch
is f6 g5 immediately uh just
breaking out on the king's side finding
counterplay over there
always going to be the correct way to go
about life
so a4 rook a3 shot king d4 played in the
game and now f6
so now let's flip the script a little
bit we're no longer trying to draw the
game with black
we are trying to win the game with white
would rick f3 have worked instead
uh so yeah rook f3 is a much better idea
here why is rick f3 a better idea
because now f6 is simply too slow you
have given white too much with rook a3
so if you do play your k3 check you got
to follow up you got to commit with
something like rook f3
or rook a2 i think rook f3 makes a bit
more sense so that this pawn can't move
and this is one of those positions where
i'm not going to be able to tell you
the evaluation um on the fly here
i think if i'm remembering correctly
this one
is also winning for white but it's like
very very difficult you have to do
things
very precisely but i might be wrong in
that that this one might be a draw i'm
not going to pretend
that i uh that i actually remember here
but yeah rook f3 would have been a much
better defensive idea after rook a3
check
that being said it's still the wrong
defensive idea when compared with the
easy draw after f6 g5
but it would be better than sort of
mixing the these ideas with rook a3 f6
so
that's that's a good comment there uh
all right the game continues now
how do we win with white
pip and chuck you gotta break your
intuition here
white is not going after the king's side
white's never going after the king's
side so
this move rook f7 is just nonsensical
first of all this is with check
second of all we're not trying to win
the kingside pawns for the queenside
pawn
we're not trying to do that we're trying
to win with the queenside pawn
so a5 yeah a5 is a perfectly reasonable
move but
inserting rook a7 first is is better why
is it better
because if you do things in the other
way then
maybe black ski is marginally better on
g6 rather than on h6 so rook a7 check is
the good way to start
now king h6 and a5
g5 okay so with white now uh black has
given you a lot
right black has done a lot for your
position
what do i mean by that well uh he's
advanced your king he's no longer
pressuring your f pawn
and uh that's a lot okay
so he's still going for this idea of g5
though so what is going
to be the winning try for white here
what's the winning try
details and end game is very important i
i agree but there are some guiding
principles
that uh hopefully you're starting to
pick up on black going for king side
play pressuring the king's side pawns
white trying to advance trying to get
the king uh
as far into the game as possible and
prevent black from making past pawns
so okay i think starting with a6 is fine
but uh i like king c5 from
from the principled perspective why do i
like king c5 by the from the principal
perspective
because we're just trying to get the
king in front of the pawn here uh you
can start with a6 though so i'm not
going to call a6 wrong at all
and honestly maybe it's even just as
just as principled
but what's the point of these moves well
the point of both moves is the same
it's to stop black from doing something
very very uh specific
so let's jump back one more time sorry
if this is confusing
we'll jump back here to the proper plane
of f6 so in this case
if white had played the move king d4
instead of h takes g5
what happens well black has a very very
easy way to draw here
and that way is to take on h4 white
takes on h4
and then black succeeds in creating the
past pawn black takes on h4
easy draw this h pawn is worth this a
pawn
and that'll be the match okay
okay if anybody disagrees with me watch
last week's lecture we went over
positions almost exactly like this
so in our game position
uh either king c5 or a6 should be played
and the reason for that
is that it prevents this idea of taking
our h-pawn
now this is the game continuation rook
a4 was played by black
but this is just a little bit of a lazy
move because rook a4 is just refuted by
by a6 black now can no longer capture
on the h4 square there just simply isn't
time
for example uh rook
d7 or c7 i think rook c7 is is probably
accurate enough
sorry hold on
this is one of those lines where i was
just like oh obviously
this is losing i remember how this is
losing i don't need to put it in the
study
but then here we are here we are
okay rook d7 i'm going to claim is the
correct idea here
and the point now is that if rook a4 you
can go king b5
and rook d4 that's the point and it's
just far too slow for black now you
can't get back behind the pawn
uh in time to draw the game that is
the point of this idea also by the way
rook d4 very cleverly stopping h4
and this is going to be too slow in this
case uh white is just close enough here
to uh to win the game okay
king b5 for example h4 uh king c4 for
example
h3 uh this i think would be a mistake
now but rook d1
and sorry should go here and now if you
do this i take this guy if you go here i
bring my king in
and win the game all right everybody
agrees everybody agrees
so rook a4 a6 android takes h4 loses
to rook d7 with this same idea and i
think honestly other things also win
here for example rk8
and a7 king g7
king b6 and this is also just in time
to win the game because this rook simply
is
not far enough away if you check me i go
here
and go rick b8 and now i win so
that's the simple line that's the simple
line rook a8 sorry
so all that is to say black is a move
too slow here with rook a4 you don't
have time to take this guy
and come back to the a file white is
able to win the game in those cases
so after a6 black is sort of just busted
and rook a4 is a wasted move
rook a2 played in the game now simply
rook a8
is the idea for white king g6 king b6
rook b2 check king a7 rick takes f2
uh by the way why does black insert rook
b2 check
because if you don't then a7 here is
going to be strong
with this idea so that's why rook b2 to
stop a7 and then rook takes f2
rook b8 now is the right idea for white
once again
aiming to go rook b5 king b6 and rook a5
this is the idea to promote the pawn or
force the rook
sacrifice the fastest you want to
interfere with the rook and the a file
rook f4 is white's idea rook or black's
idea
rook b5 rook h4 but now unfortunately
black is just a hair too slow this move
obviously loses to rook a5
but rookie 4 is a better try in the game
bringing the rook to the back rank
but now rook a5 notably rook a5
not king b7 why not king b7 because we
would much rather
stack or take back with our rook on a8
than our king
because we need our king close to the
king's side in order to win the game so
rook a5 here
and now h4 but white is winning with a
queen
if you go rook a8 by the way i'll just
go here and this has not helped you at
all
even rook takes yeah even rotates
and now they can come back so in the
game
h4 queens takes takes and then we see
king g5 and the mad dash back to the
king side starts
h3 the rook comes behind the pawn and
now
we bring the king check and
who recognizes this position you
probably should
because this has been seen in uh last
week's lecture
uh king f2 is the winning move here if
you queen
i check you take the queen and if unite
you are still doomed to failure to rook
g2 check
takes and here black
ended up resigning so we made it through
two games here um does anybody have
questions about these two games i i did
go a little bit more quickly through the
the end of that last game
but um any questions
there was a lot that we talked about
here today and a lot that we put into
practice that we talked about
in the past couple weeks but uh these
show
two examples where black was unable to
put up the correct defense
and white was able to find a way to
break through these were two pretty good
games
by by white
what happens when the black king goes to
h1 so in this last example here
if king h1 black win white wins by
pseudo still mate
uh this pawn has to move and this one
is good enough
are we doing another quick position no
no no no no time for that stuff
just a couple minutes of question and
answer
why not f4 a move to stop black by
making a passer
how do we remember all this stuff so you
don't necessarily have to remember
the specifics the point of tonight's
lecture was
to look at this more from a principled
approach in actual games so let's recap
some of those principles
right black needs to find counter play
on the king's side of the board
how do you do that well f6 g5
as we saw in this game would have been
the correct way to uh to do that you
want to make a past pawn
you want to divert your your opponent
away from the the queen side pawn
in order to to achieve that draw you
want to make a pass pawn at all costs
f6 g5 generally is a very reasonable
plan
to uh to do that what you don't want to
do is drive the king up the board as we
saw oop went back a little bit too far
there
as we saw with this awful awful move
rook a3 check
aside from that it's good of course to
keep the black king inactive and
activate your own king that's stuff that
we learned from
this game now in game number one here
it was really really crucially important
to understand
why rook f4 check wouldn't win in
general
if you can defend your pawn from the
side and defend your kingside pawns at
the same time
that's sort of your ideal case so rook
f4 check would have been white's ideal
case here
but again this plan of f6 g5 is good
enough to draw
so white goes for this instead and then
from here
in these positions f6 is not always
correct
why isn't f6 correct well first of all
the plan of g5
was too slow because a6 uh would have
been winning
do you have to remember that no you do
have to calculate that which is
unfortunate
and aside from that since f6 g5 is too
slow
f6 is a terrible terrible terrible
blunder because now
bringing this pawn to the a7 square is
simply going to be winning for white
as we saw in the game where white brings
the king
all the way over to h6
right like so like so
uh okay so final questions
what about four versus four and an extra
pawn on the queen side uh
i don't know future lecture
future lecture are there major
differences with four poems each on on
the king side i
am not confident enough to give you a
straight answer to that right now
apologies where do i find study these
positions and games
so a lot of this stuff that i've been
doing the past few weeks
is sort of sourced from doveretsky the
positions
are mostly uh shown in davoretsky's
endgame manual
and as always i would recommend you go
to
devretsky's endgame manual for a
comprehensive
um analysis of all of these positions
my goal is to make that at least a
little bit more digestible to you guys
because
in my opinion that book is a very hard
read very very hard read
okay i am going to call it here then if
you guys
are still interested in some more chess
uh the show is moving
to twitch next up so please join us on
our st louis chess club twitch channel
where i will be doing
analyzer games so send in your viewer
games and i'll analyze them
aside from that that is going to do it
for us here tonight
thank you guys so much for watching as
always my name is caleb denby and i will
see you
next time
you